so
I thought we could start with some
augmented reality but we have to talk a
little bit first about your reality
which is well this is you know this this
newspaper
I've seen it you've seen it yeah so this
is uh last Friday's paper snap logs slow
down in digital ads and so I'm not going
to read the whole story it's a great
it's a it's a great you probably didn't
think I read it I read it yeah okay well
for those that didn't read it it uh you
know it covers that the stock is down 85
percent year over year it covers uh the
outlook for next quarter isn't great
didn't even touch on your net worth so I
want to give you I'm going to give you
that but since you are in the augmented
reality business
how would you augment this reality what
do you want the picture to look like
your your camera company
oh goodness well first of all it's great
to be here
tonight I I told you we'd start soft
yeah no I know we appreciate it
um good to just Dive Right In so anyways
um
I I think you know as we look at snap
and how the business has evolved over
the last 11 years what we've really
tried to do is focus on enhancing
people's relationships with one another
with their family and friends and with
the world and we started by doing that
through our camera we focused on visual
messaging because at the time people
were using text message it was really
really slow and kind of clunky and hard
to understand how people felt when they
were just reading uh these words and so
we just we discovered that people could
communicate you know much more quickly
using images and of course videos and
sending them uh back and forth and that
use of the camera opened up a whole new
set of business opportunities for us
because it turns out you know the camera
was really being underused in terms of
just saving uh memories and you know
important moments and as soon as people
started using the camera to communicate
they also realized they could use it for
a lot of other different things like
telling stories for example or adding
content to our map so you can see what's
happening all over the world you know
near real time and most importantly now
people are using our camera for
augmented reality so 250 million people
engage with ar on Snapchat every single
day and they started out using it for
things like self-expression so in the
beginning people felt uncomfortable just
sending a selfie to their friend but if
they used AR and layered in these
creative tools right to put dog ears on
their head or help them vomit a rainbow
they felt comfortable expressing
themselves and and what we found over
time was that AR could evolve into other
more utilitarian use cases and so people
now use AR to try on a new pair of
clothes right without having to go into
a changing room and that really helps
Merchants people are using AR to extend
their concert experience we found that
artists were getting frustrated that
everyone was just holding up phones at
concerts right they felt like technology
was getting in the way of the concert
experience and artists realized that
through augmented reality they weren't
going to be able to change the fact that
people are holding up their phone but
they could make the Concert Experience
much more immersive so as we look at the
future of the camera over the next you
know 10 years and Beyond I think we're
just at the very beginning of how
augmented reality you know is really
going to bring Computing to life in the
world around us
and how does that translate to your
stock price to making the company
and and really your user base grow
I didn't realize this was an investor
meeting
um so we're gonna we're gonna get to the
augmented I I think I think what we
found over the years is just by focusing
on our community which is now I think
363 million daily active users and
bringing them products that they really
love and enjoy and then figuring out of
course how to you know monetize our
community I think now we're about on a
five billion dollar run rate in terms of
Revenue
um you know which I think at the time
when we were just starting Snapchat and
just playing around with visual
messaging nobody thought uh was possible
but I I think again just staying focused
on our community on giving people
products that they uh really love and
then of course working to you know help
our partners grow their businesses
through advertising or you know
expanding the opportunity we have with
our subscription product called Snapchat
Plus which gives people experimental
products and features or ar Enterprise
which takes all of our air technology
and tools and helps embed it in other
people's applications and websites these
are all ways that you know we can make
money and and of course generate more
cash flow which should translate into a
higher share price but I think all of
that you know comes after really serving
our community with products that they
love
and when I sort of hear you talk about a
lot of these problems I wonder how some
of the problems around the stock price
could just be solved by you not being a
public company
do you do you have these moments of
wishing you know a few years ago maybe
shouldn't have gone public maybe but it
was a different route
well I think you know if you believe
that your own personal scorecard is the
stock price being a public company is a
terrible idea and I certainly wouldn't
recommend it I think for us if you look
at snap and the reason why people come
to snap and want to be a part of our
team of course it's you know for the
vision you know of empowering people to
express themselves and live at the
moment and learn about the world and
have fun together it's the you know the
scale of our reach 363 million uh daily
actives and it's the impact because
we're only a team of about 5 000 people
serving 360 to 3 million people every
single day and so that is really
motivating and inspiring to our team and
and I don't think they you know use the
the stock price to to measure their
success and I think they believe that if
we continue to focus on the inputs like
I mentioned things like you know serving
our community that over the long term
the stock price uh will sort itself out
all right so you're hoping Elon Musk
does not call and
offer any money he has left
um I want to talk so you mentioned
around augmented reality the idea of
sort of going Beyond filters
how do you get more people to think
because one of the things I love about
using the app is that I I've tried on
shoes right I can try on shoes I can see
how that looks I can try on makeup how
do you get your users to think Beyond I
mean how do you and as you're looking at
the design of that app how do you think
Beyond
this is just fun lenses
well I wouldn't underestimate the power
of fun I mean we always talk about this
eems quote that toys are the preludes to
Serious ideas right and and this idea is
that if you can really entertain people
and give them something that they enjoy
doing that you know that's the beginning
of building uh a big business so you
know when we first were uh playing
around with Tryon of clothing it was
virtual clothing just stuff that we
thought was fun and silly it wasn't
until much later that we started working
with luxury Brands to bring you know
true size sunglasses into our products
so that people could actually see what
they look like and you know convert
through the application so I wouldn't
underestimate the power of fun and
giving people new ways to express
themselves and over time those can
evolve into quite meaningful businesses
when you think about sort of adding that
the well are you still a camera company
I was going to ask a lot of questions
about the camera but I just want to do
you think of it as still you're a camera
company
we are a camera company and that's why
we open directly into the camera I mean
unlike so many products that open into a
feed of other people's content we've
always opened into your own experience
of the world around you and then overlay
that of course with augmented reality
but we still believe that the camera is
going to be you know the most
transformational tool over the next
decade
tick tock
how much do you hate them
I I would use the word admire admire
them okay
but but fundamentally it's a different
product right
um we've had discussions about this
before right and you open up to the
camera you want people to share Tick
Tock opens up to an algorithmic feed
that is going to keep you there for
hours now of course that's why
engagement is up on that app but when
you think about it when you use tick
tock are there parts of that that make
you think we maybe miss the boat on
certain things or you've worked into the
product
uh well really I think Tick Tock just
represents the power of using algorithms
to personalize content which is
something that we've focused on for a
long time through our Discover product
and you know I remember in the early
days uh when bite dance had a product
called totiao which was really a news
Reader application they were innovating
because they said look people aren't
going to just read the content that
their friends are reading they're going
to want to read content that's
personalized for them and we're going to
use machine learning to do that and so
we learned a lot from that and we use
machine learning a lot to rank discover
content and of course rank Spotlight
content and make recommendations and so
we're always trying to learn from what
Innovative companies are doing and it's
certainly true that people prefer
content that's personalized for them I
think you know building a business
around a feed is very challenging
because it's difficult to differentiate
and that's why we focus so much on
visual messaging between friends and
family because people always want to
talk to their friends they always want
to talk to their family and so they come
into our service all day long to do that
and then we can offer them other
products like our AR platform or our map
or of course our content products as
well yeah so it sort of strikes me as
you guys can be this idea of the super
app
tell me what tell me what you think
about when you hear the word super app
too because we've heard a lot about this
over the last number of weeks from Elon
Musk and others
I think that idea really comes from
seeing the role that messaging apps have
played in China and we were very
fortunate early on to learn a lot from
tencent who has a very big business that
really was built around messaging
because they discovered that if people
were talking to their friends all day
long they could learn from what people
were doing and they you know in the
early days saw that people were leaving
conversations with their friends to play
games and so they realized oh if we just
build games into our messenger then
maybe people will play games together
and continue having those conversations
and they were able to build a massive
gaming business and over time they just
learned that that frequency of
Engagement around messaging can allow
you to build a very powerful application
that stretches Beyond messaging and into
other areas of delivering value to your
community so we certainly learned a lot
from that and that's why we've been able
to expand our platform over time into
all these different areas is do you
think that the U.S market fundamentally
struggles with this
I I think where the U.S market and
Western markets have struggled is
typically in in the payments area so one
of the things that was very interesting
about the early days of Messengers in in
China was that there weren't necessarily
the same sort of established payment
rails that there are here and in you
know Western Europe for example and so
there emerged a lot of payment use cases
in those applications that we don't
necessarily see replicated here in the
United States just because we have you
know I think more of this Legacy
infrastructure and well well we'll shift
gears in a second I want to talk about
more AR and metaverse but when you think
about
your user base well let's just do a show
of hands how many people here use snap
how many people here's kids use snap
okay
as you expand into AR as you want to
grow the user base and engagement how do
you capture more of this audience or
even younger audiences
well what we found to be most effective
is to just grow with our community one
of the things that we found is that once
people learn how to use visual messaging
and they you know are able to see what
their friends are up to all day long and
communicate in that really rich and
emotional and exciting way they don't
want to go back to text message or the
telephone and so what we've really tried
to focus on doing is building Innovative
products and then giving them to the
demographic that's most excited to try
them which happens to be young people
normally
um and so that's really been our
strategy over time that if we're going
to innovate we want to give those
Innovations to the most engaged and
excited demographic that is always
looking to try new stuff and then as
long as we can continue to deliver real
value to our community they'll stay with
us and grow with us and that that's why
today you know I think we reached more
than 75 percent of 13 to 34 year olds in
more than 20 countries you know that's
like the US and UK and France and you
know et cetera so
um you know that that's really been our
approach to aging up is just continuing
to deliver a lot of value to our
community as they grow with us yeah I
definitely find that because people I
find especially around people that read
news on there it's like they've been
reading the Wall Street Journal for
years on through the app and you can
tell that they've sort of followed along
so I want to ask you to finish this
sentence
the metaverse is
living inside a computer
you don't want to do that
the last thing I want to do when I get
home from work at the end of the long
day is is live inside a computer so
what are you yeah no no no please finish
your thought
what about you inside a computer if you
don't finish your thought
s what I was going to say I think we're
just at such an interesting time in
Computing so you know if you look at the
last you know what 20 30 years Computing
has evolved enormously from the
Mainframe desktop laptop you know now
it's inside your pocket on your
smartphone and Computing has gotten a
lot more personal it's gotten more
interactive it's gotten more immersive
um certainly gotten more uh social and
and I think what's what's clearly been
driving that Trend right is is really a
desire for computers to to be more
portable to be you know lighter to make
it easier to get them out of the way to
put them out of the way and what we
think is so interesting is that there's
such a clear fork in the road at this
moment where you have a group of people
who's talking a lot about the future of
computing in terms of virtual reality
which you know as I mentioned is a lot
of like you know this vision of living
inside a computer and then there's this
whole other uh group you know like us
that are really focused on augmented
reality which is really about harnessing
the power of computing well getting it
out of the way right and I think we just
talked to so many people that feel like
Computing or even their phones get in in
the way of enjoying the world around
them and that they want to immerse
themselves more in in the world around
them they really enjoy reality and they
feel like Computing puts a lot of
friction in the way of that and so the
promise of augmented reality is to give
you all those benefits of computing
without a lot of that friction without
the feeling that your computer is you
know making you stay at your desk or is
you know you've got you fixated on this
tiny little screen so that's that's why
we're so excited about augmented reality
and I'm excited about it too but I think
and as I've written about this like we
don't quite know what that app is that
killer app that is going to make us want
to put on
the glasses or even hold the phone up
right
will you guys figure that out will that
be some other company that figures that
out will it be the hardware makers that
figure that out
I'm not sure it's necessarily going to
be one killer app which is why we're so
focused on building this developer or
Community there are now hundreds of
thousands of developers who are building
these augmented reality experiences
called lenses on Snapchat there are
millions of these lenses that have been
created and you can easily bring them
across to our glasses called spectacles
we we currently release them only for
developers but people are building all
sorts of really interesting experiences
and I think a lot of the hints for
what's to come in the future can
actually be found on on the smartphone
today much like people were using you
know instant messaging on the desktop
before it exploded on on the smartphone
and so when we look at what's happening
on on Snapchat uh today and we we see
the way that you know people are
learning about the world through
augmented reality there was a great lens
this week that shows people how to do
you know CPR in augmented reality and
it's really different than watching a
static video or clicking through uh you
know some some pictures when you can
really see what it's like you know it
helps you learn faster because that
learning is much more
experiential so you know I've of course
shared some of the examples around
shopping or around more immersive
concert experiences I think all of those
are early glimpses into how glasses will
be used in the future but the experience
on glasses is just so much more
compelling because it's truly immersive
are you guys going to make the glasses I
mean let's talk about hardware for a
second so this is the pixie this is your
drone let's see if it's like I want to
try to fly it up here I think I mean how
many of you guys have seen this work
see nobody knows how it works okay so
let's see how it goes
you're scared terrified okay I'm just
gonna take a picture together it's gonna
be okay
uh this is the one I want right
right let's see
it's not windy don't worry
it's totally fine
up up okay it's finding its way
[Music]
all right he's gonna go backwards
I put on the reverse I thought here hold
on all right
so this is a completely
it's a completely well you tell you how
does this work
uh
what we discovered is that people really
wanted more ways to to make videos that
they couldn't necessarily make with
their phones uh and and so we uh figured
out how to how to build a drone that'll
follow you around and coming back and
land in the palm of your hand and one of
the things that that I've really enjoyed
doing is making a bunch of fun uh videos
with with our kids running around I mean
you realize as a parent oh oh it's going
keep going you realize as a parent how
few videos you have together with your
children you know you're always the one
holding holding the phone and so to be
able to play in the backyard and make
you know really uh Priceless video uh
with Pixie is a lot of fun so there we
go
okay so I so here's the thing
this thing's amazing right it comes
right back to you
come on come on little guy come on you
got it you got it no no no no don't make
me get up
I loved this thing
I thought it was so fun
and now I gotta ask you why do you why'd
you kill this baby
I'm gonna make I don't want to make you
cry it's it is it is a uh fabulous and
low margin uh product for
yeah
uh in a world of five percent rates so
it's uh that that was a really fun
product and you know obviously
heartbreaking to discontinue something
like that but we're really focused uh
you know really on on three key areas as
a business continuing to grow our
community of course around the world uh
you know re-accelerating our Revenue
growth which uh you know as you
mentioned is very important and um and
investing in augmented reality which is
just so critical to our long-term future
and that and that you know sort of focus
means making hard uh decisions like you
know uh shutting down a product that we
really love but I think there are a few
uh left so while supplies last you can
probably uh grab one special rate for
everybody
but but just to be clear it's not the
end of hardware for snap you still want
to make Hardware no not at all because
we're we're really using Hardware to
explore what the future of augmented
reality is is going to look like I mean
you know eight years ago when we started
working on augmented reality and put
inside the Snapchat application we saw
how engaging it was for people who are
using our products and playing around
with with lenses and it was so engaging
on this tiny little screen where you
have to use your thumbs to navigate and
we were like wow you know what if this
were much more immersive right rather
than you know being stuck staring at
this tiny screen AR is actually overlaid
in the world around you you can use your
hands you can walk around uh you know
you could use Computing in a totally uh
different way I mean there's such a
there's a hilarious little game
um in spectacles where you kind of have
a zombie chase you around it's perfect
for Halloween but but the first thing
that people realize is that they can
move and that's something that's so
different than the way that we're used
to using Computing today whether it's on
our phone and we're afraid of falling
over something walking down the side you
know sidewalk or you've got V ER on
you're worried about banging into a lamp
or something and in your house when you
realize that you can use AR get the
benefits of computing but move around in
the world around you it's really
compelling and and no one was working on
you know consumer grade AR glasses at
the time so we just decided to take a
very deliberate step-by-step approach
you know starting with camera glasses
eventually adding displays and and now
we've got a product you know product
that's out there that developers are
using to build really compelling
experiences
it feels like a lot of meta's Ambitions
in AR and VR are a little bit fueled by
the fact that in the mobile ecosystem
they didn't have control of their
operating system they didn't have
control of the hardware
is that as you think about that and you
head into this next wave of computing
are you thinking about how much you can
control that platform is that part of
this
no it's it's really not so much about
control it's really about unlocking the
potential of augmented reality which
today is very constrained by the
capabilities of the smartphone and don't
get me wrong AR is going to evolve like
crazy on the smartphone over the next
you know decade but to really you know
unlock the full potential I think it
requires more immersive technology
I want to ask about Apple has obviously
you guys started on the the iPhone and
uh I want to ask you know we're going to
have two apple Executives here after and
one of them who specifically worked on
the app transparency uh feature uh ATT
which limited your ability to Target ads
on in snap
you've said previously you know you were
you're okay with that move how do you
feel about that now do you blame any of
the current issues that we talked about
in that paper on on that move
well when we go back to the the
beginning of Snapchat one of the things
that we have always really cared about
is privacy I mean we were really the
first to Pioneer ephemeral
Communications this idea that you know
to make your digital Communications more
like real life conversations they should
just be deleted after you have them
instead of being stored forever and at
the time you know people really
questioned that approach uh now today I
think people have realized the value of
privacy and how important that is when
when we started working on our ad
platform we did it in a way that we
could protect our community's privacy
and we we you know never offered some of
them much more privacy invasive you know
device level targeting that that other
platforms did because we didn't think
that was the right thing to do for our
community and and I think what we've
seen over the past uh you know several
years is that people's trust in online
platforms has been eroded because they
feel like their privacy has been
compromised or you know they've
witnessed uh you know disinformation and
I think that's very harmful to the
industry overall and so when Apple
announced uh these changes you know we
we were extremely worried that they
would be disruptive and they certainly
have then but we also made clear that we
were aligned with you know the the uh
overall goal of really trying to improve
privacy you know for uh users of of
Apple phones but also more broadly in
the industry so I think it's very
important for maintaining long-term
trust with uh people who use technology
products uh but it's it's certainly
disruptive and continues to be and you
know I think the the good thing I'm
optimistic because Apple does continue
to iterate they're now on their fourth
version of SK ad Network they're making
improvements and so while this
transition has been disrupted I see a
real commitment from the Apple team you
know to continue to improve so so that
their developers can can be successful
on their platform and one thing that I
think get showed largely in an industry
is the dependence on data and the data
needed for advertising you guys have
rolled out Snapchat Plus which is a
subscription offering is there a future
where where more people pay to use
social media maybe even with the hope
that not as much data is collected
oh gosh I you know I would separate the
two in a sense because you know when we
look at when you when you talk about
data collection right what you're really
talking about is the inverse of great
recommendations and if you look at where
technology is going in the future it's
really dependent on great
recommendations that's why technology
makes our lives so much easier you know
the services that we use understand our
preferences it understands what you know
what people like us also enjoy so that
it can help us find that information in
formation much more easily uh so so I I
think that you know platforms are going
to continue to find ways to collect out
in a privacy Safe Way and use that data
to make great recommendations and that
that really underpins I I think a lot of
where technology is continuing to go in
in the future but I do think there's a
huge opportunity for us to add more
value to our community Through products
and features and our subscription
business is a great way to align one of
the things that we've you know feel like
we've been good at and really enjoy
which is making stuff uh Innovative
stuff that people like to use and so we
figured out out that you know a
subscription business could really align
our desire to you know really make
products for we got this great uh group
of people on Snapchat who use our
service you know 90 out of 90 days or
something like that and and they really
have specific requests for us of
features that they'd really love but
those features have been harder for us
to prioritize because we're often
prioritizing things that benefit our
entire Community but by offering this
subscription product we can super serve
that Community that's really passionate
about Snapchat and you know charge a
small amount 399 a month for those
special features so it's very early but
you know I think within three months of
launching Snapchat Plus we have a
million and a half paying subscribers so
it's a decent you know start and we'll
just continue iterating and dropping new
features on a regular basis no that
makes that makes total sense I want to
sort of end with so where we are right
now in the tech landscape you've got
it's an interesting time right meta is
struggling with Focus Google seems to
have turned into the post office they
are you know trying to focus on how to
be more efficient uh it's unclear uh
you've got Amazon admitting that it's
bloated
is there a benefit to being smaller
right now
you're pretty tough on some some iconic
companies
um wow uh yeah
if Google's the post office then we're
really screwed uh no this uh
uh
you're gonna be great at delivering mail
I I think
no I I think there's tremendous
opportunity for SNAP we're really
fortunate to be growing our business you
know as you mentioned on a much smaller
base with a smaller team with a ton of
opportunity in front of us so just in
terms of where we are in our our life
cycle there's an enormous amount of
opportunity even just in in the near
term in terms of the growth of our
community you know our Revenue you know
if you look at our average revenue per
user I think we're still a fraction of
Twitter's average revenue per user even
though our community in in the United
States you know at least in terms of
like daily active users or month mdau is
like double I think so um you know I
think the scale of our platform means
we've got a ton of opportunity and and
you know the ability to to be nimble and
adapt to what is a very volatile
operating environment and I wanted to
ask too as a leader just you know to
sort of reflect as you've obviously had
a rough couple months from layoffs and
yes yes the paper
um how have have you've navigated that
and have you learned anything to you
know impart to people in the audience
that that also have to sort have managed
through tough times
yeah well this this article was a lot
better than one you all wrote in 2018
which was brutal uh but uh
I I think ultimately the thing that
motivates us is serving our community
and at the end of the day and and early
in the morning uh that's that's what
drives us to do the work that we do
um so so I think as long as we can
continue to to Delight our community
that again the rest sort of takes care
of takes care of itself and and so I
think for other leaders out there who
are working through these really
challenging times I see them motivated
by a lot of similar things they're
motivated by customers they're motivated
by uh innovating and and I think you
know right now
um you know it's really a time for
businesses to work together to navigate
these challenges we've certainly tried
to really make an effort to Super serve
our partners and our community during
this challenging period of time because
ultimately you know while it can be
really tempting and a tough moment to
focus inwards to focus on your own
business I think what we've always found
whether it was navigating the pandemic
or some of our early business challenges
focusing on our community and our
partners and and making sure that you
know we're really delivering results for
them m is always what you know leads to
long-term growth
so much
as The Parting Gift I give you that
paper but thank you so much really
appreciate you coming
[Applause]